Weslie, Kevin,
congratulations.
You smiths are in the
third and final round
of this competition.
Now, when you came here,
we had you forge signature
blades to a nautical theme.
Now, we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
That is the pira.
And I can tell by the look
of feara on your faces,
you're not looking
forward to this one.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck, man.
Good luck on you too.
This day one and we're about
to get started on this pira.
I'm going to be
making a Damascus.
It looks pretty.
Shows a bit of skill.
And I'm hoping that
this Damascus will
beat out a monosteel blade.
OK, and into the forge we go.
I'm using 10 84 and 15
and 20 for my billets.
As I'm forge loading it,
I'm looking for the scale
to start coming
off as big flakes,
because that means that
they've all welded together.
I'm going back between the
forge, the power hammer.
It's hot, very hot.
It's the end of day one.
I've got my build
all forged out,
but it's still really rough.
Still got a lot of work to do.
[music playing]
So I'm back in
Ozark, Missouri,
in the shop I share with
other local knivesmiths here.
And I'm going to be making
and working on the pira.
Most of the knives that I
make stop at the longest,
like, eight inches.
So just the size of
it is rather daunting.
The smell of propane.
I want to be able to bring
something to the judges
that they will say, wow.
So I decide to go with
a Damascus pattern.
I am going to use
10 84 and 15 and 20.
I'm going to make a
handful of small billets
that I will eventually combine.
One giant billet would be
really hard to work with.
So I want to make the smaller
billets to make it manageable.
I need the clean up the
faces that will be touching,
simply because it'll
help for a cleaner weld.
At the end of day one, I have
five tiny billets that I will
be able to start with day two.
Put those together, and that
will be the basis for my sword.
It looked awesome.
Start of day three,
I got my handle shaped.
And I've even gotten a chance
to start carving on it.
Today's agenda is heat treats.
Hopefully, I'll be able
to keep it straight.
I pulled out the quench.
There's a little
bit of warp in it.
It's pulling off to the right.
Son of a gun.
I open up the oven.
I take out the blade.
And the entire blade's cracked.
[beep] me.
This blade's done.
It must have been under so much
stress that it just snapped.
It's time to get forging again.
Plan B is to just
go on the monosteel.
I don't have time to make
another billet of Damascus.
Just adrenaline pumping
through me right about now.
It's just go, go, go.
I would have liked
to have not broken
the blade I've been
kind of working
on for the past two days.
But got another blade
forged out in record time.
Ended up taking
me a lot longer
to draw out my Damascus billet.
I've spent two full
days making the steel
I need to even make this pira.
Today, I'm just nervous about
getting this blade done.
I need to get this thing shaped.
I start to work in my swell.
But as I continue
to stretch my metal,
I'm noticing that it is
getting dangerously thin.
I stick it back to kind of
straighten everything out,
and I just watch it lean.
It won't survive the quench.
It just won't.
So two and 1/2 days in, I'm
starting over with a monosteel.
I grab my bar of 51 60 and
into the forge it goes.
Having to start over halfway
through day three is--
it sucks.
It really sucks.
But I'm going to push as hard
as I can to get this thing done.
This is our day four.
Still got a lot of work to do.
I gotta basically
finish the entire knife.
I'm going to fit up the guard.
From there, I just
go into my handle
and just, you know,
sanding everything,
making it all nice and smooth.
There you are.
I get on my wire wrap.
I carve a little relief
going from the hole
to the outside of the handle.
That way, the wire will
actually lay flush.
I also do a little
trick where I just stick
a little toothpick in there
to kind of mechanically
lock the wire.
I do edge one final time.
And with that, I'm done.
I can't wait to see
what Doug does with it.
Day four, and I have to make
a pira in basically one day.
I got the profile of
the blade forged out.
I need to finish grinding.
I need to quench.
And I have to put
the handle together.
Pull it out, and it's
warped just a little bit.
At this point, I'll take it.
I start to work on my handle.
This handle is hard to do it
because the tail is coming
off at a really weird angle.
The fitting of it,
everything takes time
that I do not have right now.
I don't have the
luxury of add pins.
But I've got to get
it stuck together.
So five minute epoxy it is.
I'm done.
There's nothing else I can do.
I'm out of time.
I'm not turning in exactly
what I wanted to turn in,
but there's no quit in me.
And because of that, I
have a finished pira.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
Your piras look
very interesting.
Now it's time to find
out how lethal they are.
To find that out, I
will take your piras
and deliver some slashes and
hacks on this boar carcass.
Kevin, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Oh, yeah.
Let's do this.
This is a big hog.
You know, it's got hide.
It's got bones.
It's got meat.
And I'm going to have
to go through all of it.
Chills down my spine.
Butterflies in my stomach.
Hopefully, everything
I did will hold up.
[music playing]
All right, Kevin, let's
talk about your pira here.
You, sir, have captured
the spirit of what
this weapon is all about.
The flair that you have
there actually really allows
me to really get a good grip.
You have a forward
weight, but it's
perfectly placed right where the
sweet spot is, making every cut
very deep.
Nothing wrong with the edge.
It's still razor sharp,
and it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Weslie,
ready to chop some pork?
Ready as I'll ever be.
All right, let's do it.
I am quite literally
shaking in my boots.
This is a big pig.
All I can think is, my handle
is going to bust in two.
I don't see a pin here.
Is there any mechanical
connection at all that's
holding this right in there?
I didn't have time.
I understand.
There's no mechanical
connection here.
Usually, when they whisper,
this is a really bad sign.
I don't want to hold back.
Holding back is not a
fair way to test it.
Weslie, this is always
tough for any smith.
We understand that the
problems you had at home
kind of bit you when it came
to finishing that blade.
Right now, the handle of your
blade is held in place by glue.
There are no mechanical
connections in the handle.
A "Forged in Fire"
champion would make sure
that their weapon
is made to withstand
pushing a blade to the absolute
limits of what's possible.
And unfortunately, we can't
engage your weapon like that.
For that reason,
please exit the forge.
Come on forward.
Thank you.
To push as hard as I
felt like I pushed,
and get here and not have
it tested, it's a bummer.
Good job.
I understand why and
I agree, but I mean,
kind of would have been
cool to at least see it
bust halfway through a pig.
But I was still able to
at least present something
to them to show them
that I don't quit.
I don't give up.
And I am very proud
of myself for that.
Kevin, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And that it's a title that
comes with a check for $10,000.
Good job, my friend.
You did fantastic work.
You deserve it.
Come over here and
shake our hands.
To everybody who's ever
dogged me, you know, here I am.
I'm standing champion
of "Forged in Fire."
I would've liked to have
gotten through all three tests.
But I've proven that not only
do I make the stuff I make,
but I make it pretty
damn good as well.
I just won "Forged in Fire."
[laughs] Oh, man.